[音楽]
ブードゥー君
みなさんこんにちは
レッドとずうですけれども皆さんに一つ質問させてください
皆さんが今一番感じておられるコンプレックス
劣等感ってなんでしょうか
コンプレックスといってもですね様々なものがあると思います
例えば少しぽっちゃりされていることをコンプレックスというふうに感じておられる方
もいらっしゃるかもしれませんしあるいは
まあ田舎の方言がですね思わず親しい友達との間で出てしまった
こんなことで
ですねー
コンプレックスというふうに関しておられる方もひょっとしたらいらっしゃるかもしれ
ません
ちなみですけれども私の場合はですね
この薄毛がコンプレックスでした
私はおととしまで22年間サラリーマンをした後にです
従来の
隠す増やす方法以外の方法で
薄毛に悩む人たちに対して新しい
見せると魅力のみと書いてみせるというコンセプトを提供したいとそういう気持ちを
持ってですね
起業しました
牛性研究家です
今から15年ほど前になりますけれども昔それほど親しくなかった
女性がですね sns で友達申請をしてきました
私はそう申請に対して何の躊躇もなく
鍾乳ボタンを押したところですねきっとこんなですね
私のみすぼらしい写真が
彼女の pc のディスプレイにどーんと表示されたんだと思いますここ笑うところ
です
お願いしますん
それでですねまあいきなりまあテキストですですねまぁきっと彼女も驚いたんだと思い
ます
到来したその頭をここを笑うところですお願いしますありがとうございます
それでどないもこないもノアやろうとまぁ普通の人は思うと思うんですけれども私は
それを思いつつですね
まあこの盗難したその頭っていうですねあのテキストですね
しばし呆然と見つめてですね
まあ少なからずまあ凹んでですね大いにショックを受けました
もともとですね薄毛であるということについては私自身コンプレックスとして考えては
思ってましたので
まあより一層ですねこの事件以降私クドないしたその頭事件で買って読んでますけれど
も同じ傾向ですね
一層移行後に勤しもうというふうに決意をした
まそんな出来事でした
まぁしかしですねまぁ同時に自分が元々持って抱かれ性格っていうのがどんどん内向的
になっていって
挙句の果てにはですねできるだけ昔の私の姿を知ってる人たちが集まる場には行かない
でおこうとそういうことまで思うようになりました
まあ薄毛をですねどうにもできないこのままならなさとですね
その当時の自分を受けられ受け入れられることができないこの悔しいセンサーに対して
ですね
まあどう対処していればいいのかということでついて全くことは答えが見つかりません
でした
まあですですけれどもまあ対処の仕方がわからない一方でです
なんで
髪の毛が豊かな人がしなくてもいい
髪の毛を増やすあるいは頭皮を隠すっていうことをやらなくちゃいけないのか
っていうですねまぁ非常に素朴な疑問が湧いてきたんです
なぜそのままでいることがダメなのかあるいはダメな空気があるのか
これはひょっとしては何もカメラを気に限った話じゃないかもしれません
ひょっとしたら他のコンプレックスについても同じようなことが言えるのかもしれませ
ん
私は自分の体験で日本という社会はですね
極めてコンプレックスというものに対して厳しい
あるいは許容範囲が狭い社会なんじゃないだろうか
そんな想いを持ちました
ここにですね私がたった2日間で女性350人以上にとったアンケートがあります
これによるとですね薄毛であるということは女性から見た場合
交際する際にですね決して致命的にネガティブな要素ではないということが言えると
思いますこれものすごい勇気づけられました
そしてですね薄毛の男性はにあってらを好きというふうにおっしゃってくれる方が
73%
4人でサーフィンもいるんですこれはすごいことだと私は思いました
そして
堂々と見せているのと隠しているのだとどっちの方が許せるかという話ですと堂々と
見せている方がいいという方がほぼ9割いらっしゃる
そして短くすることに対しての好感度はめちゃめちゃ高い
ですね出すのでまぁ何が言いたいかと言うと決して女性から見たときにですね
髪の毛が薄いということが許されないんではなくてですね
隠そうとするということがですねあまり好まれてないんじゃないかということがまあ
ここで言えるのではないだろうかというふうに思うわけです
ご存知の方もいらっしゃるかと思いますけれども
ひとたび海外に目を向けると
確かにカッコいいと言われるような薄毛男性は言います
これは何でだと思いますか皆さん
不思議だと思いませんか同じハゲ薄毛なのにねっ
まあ私はですねあのうすべに限らず
こんぷれっつといわれるものの多くは実はですね
その人の有力な個性であったりあるいは場合によってはですね
武器にさえが柳龍ではないだろうかまあそんな可能性を感じ始めています
そして本人はもちろんのことですね
周囲の人たちもコンプレックス a の6型方が変われば
コンプレックスという概念そのものがなくなる歳するのではないだろうか
そんなことを期待しています
薄毛に悩む男性はですね薄毛を恥ずかしいというふうに思っています
そしてその恥ずかしい気持ちによってとってしまう構造によってですね
周りの人たちは結果的にジロジロ見たり弄ったりというネガティブな行動を起こして
しまいがちです
よくですねあの
薄毛の男性に対して堂々としてりゃいいじゃんとポジティブになればいいじゃんって
いうですね
私からしたらですね非常にまあ迷惑であり無責任なですね
アルファ椅子をされる方がいらっしゃるんですけれどもこれでは本人の恥ずかしい
気持ち
あるいはですね周りの偏見っていうのも
ですねなくなることはありません
ですけれどもこれが何かしらのきっかけで例えば本人を
コニーがですね外見を変えてみるそんなことをするだけですね周りの人たちが
受け入れる
そうするとですねまぁポジティブなメッセージを本人が受け取るというようなことが
起きていきます
するとその変化を感じた人たちがまた本人がまたさらにその自信を獲得していくという
ようなですねまぁこいつディープなサイクルっていうのが回り始めるわけです
まあコンプレックスがですねコンプレックスなくなる唯一の方法は本人と周りの人たち
のこの両方がですね
受け入れているという状況をつくるしかないんです
それではですね行ってどうすれば本人と周りの人たちの間にですね
良好かつ居心地のいい
空気母兄というのは作れるんでしょうか
私は同じ薄毛であってもですねかっこいい本人とそれをいじらない周りの人たちがいる
もうこれを作るしかないっていうふうに思いました
そのためにはですねまず最初に薄毛の男性が従来の隠す増やすではなくてですね
周りの人たちが納得してそして受け入れることのできる薄毛ガス薄着が似合う
スキルノウハウこれをですねマスターして実践することが大事だという風に考えている
んです
しかもそのスキルやノウハウっていうのは小手先の手法や根性論には頼らず科学的な
根拠に基づいたアプローチが必要だという風に考えているわけです
そこでまず最初にご紹介したいのが
顔中新コンセプトそしてバストアップ中新コンセプトというアイディアです
これはですね女性の間では割と知られているテクニックですけれども
ポイントをつけることによって周りの人たちからの視線をうまく来とるしていくという
まあ一つの技術です
他人の目線っていうのは最も目立つ場所に集中するというふうに言われています
例えば服の上下を分ける分割星の位置あるいは襟元や胸元にですね
ネックレスやブローチをつけることによって相手の視線っていうのは自在に変えること
ができます
原理ですね
服の分割背を高く上げるあるいは高い位置にブローチをつけるということによって手軽
ですね
スタイルを良く見せたりあるいは背を高く見せるって言うことができるわけです
これをですね薄毛男性に応用してみようというのがですね
個々の考え方なんです
薄毛男性の場合ですねジャケットやネクタイ小物をですねうまく組み合わせることに
よって印象を大幅に変えることができます
特に胸から上のバストアップっていう部分になりますけれどもね来たよチーフをですね
派手にすることでは他人の視線をですね
変えられるコントロールできるということですね
私自身もみもみ思ってですね経験することをしています
次にご紹介したい理論が縦横比理論っていう理論です
これは頭頂部に髪の毛がある方にとってみれば非常に有効な理論だと思います
顔のタテハはですね頭頂部から唇場で垂直に降ろした距離
そして横幅ですね耳を除いて左右の幅を取ったと最大幅ですねこれを取った所ですね
いわゆるハリウッドとかあるいは映画スターでかっこいいスキンヘッドあるいは薄毛
配布されていらっしゃいますけれどもこの人たちが比率っていうのが軒並み切って2倍
から入って3倍あることが分かりました
それで対してですね
日本人の薄毛男性というのは軒並み入って1倍を割り込むということがわかってしまい
ました
ひとによっては横幅の方が縦幅よりも距離が長いという決済あったんです
現在ですね非常に真面目でですね大阪大学と共同研究を行っているんですけれども
ヘアースタイルを変えることによってこの縦横比をですね
入って2倍程度にすると最も印象が良くなるということが
明らかになってきています
写真の左側がですね髪の毛で頭皮を隠していた5年前の私です
このころが入って08倍でした
そして真ん中が
1.17倍
それで一番右端が1.29倍です
皆さんからご覧になってですね同写真が最も印象が良いでしょうか
同様にですね
他の薄毛男性モデルのカット前とカット後の違いを見てみたいと思います
感心して頂きましてありがとうございます
皆さんですねカット後の縦横比は1.2倍から一転3倍になっています
私が確認したところ男女を問わずほぼすべての人柄
カット後の方の写真の方が印象がいいという傾向が見られました
実を言いますとですね
ここで言いたいのは単に壁方を変えることで
周囲の人たちからのば印象が変わるっていうことではなくてですね
まあ私を含めたこの人たちのですね
カット前とカット後での中身の変化です
気持ちの変化がすごく大きいんです
実を言うとですね薄着にどの程度悩んでたかっていうのはですね
まあこの人たちと私もそうですけれども人それぞれでしたけれども皆さん
カット後にですねご家族あるいは職場の方々にですね
見てもらってですねよくなったねとか垢抜けたねと言っても割れる
薄毛な
て褒められることで合わないんですよねですけど褒められるとすごく自信を取り戻す
ことができたというお言葉をですね
もらったという話を聞きました
実際ですね職場での人間関係が劇的に向上してですね
仕事のパフォーマンスが上がったというですねお話を聞きます
まあこれまでのようにですね壁を気を失う過程で失った自信がですね
こういう形で取り戻すことができてそして生きること自体にもですね
積極的になれるということが言えるかというふうに思います
私自身もですねそれまで薄毛で見られてるのではないだろうかというふうに思ってです
ね
まあ無意識のうちに頭皮を少ない壁ですね隠すというですね
無駄な抵抗ずっとし続けてました
そしてですねまあそういうことを繰り返していくとですねどんどんマイナス思考になっ
ていくんですけれども
髪の毛を切ることによって自分の長所や魅力を磨くということに
視線が向いたとしてが動いたということでポジティブなサイクルが回り始めました
私はコンプレックスというものは誰しもが持っているものであって
コンプレックスあること自体はごく自然なことだというふうに思っています
しかしコンプレックスを持つ本人も周りの人たちも来プレックスに対して寄り添うこと
がこれまでできただろうか
そんなことを思うわけです
先ほどのですね
恥ずかしいと思う本人と周りの人たちの頭を思い出していただきたいというふうに思い
ます
コンプレックスというものは
決して悪いものではなくてうまく付き合うことが大事なんじゃないだろうかという風に
考えています
つまり本人の恥ずかしい感情と周りの人たちからの偏見
この両方からですね立ち向かうことが出来れば受け入れ会える
そんな可能性が広がっていくというふうに思っています
そして結果として居心地のよい
空気社会そういったものが作れるのではないだろうかというふうな希望を持っています
恥という感情はですね本人の気持ちだけではなくてですね
周りの人たちがどう感じているかということも非常に重要な鑑定家といえるかと思い
ます
さて皆さんに最初にご想像いただいた
を墓地皆さんがお持ちのコンプレックスというものはどのようにすれば
コンプレックスを持つ本人と周囲の人達の両方が受け入れ合いそうでしょうか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]